thank you
shall we
shall we
is that you
like 24 to New York hey Shelby
oh man you act like you don't know me
huh please don't make a scene oh you
didn't say that when you was crashing my
wedding don't worry I'm getting on the
flight thank you for the economy plus
ticket I'll enjoy that bag of pretzels
you'll never see me again [ __ ]
everywhere everywhere I turn you're on a
goddamn billboard on the Twitter feed on
on my TV screen everywhere I look you're
like a damn ninja you're gonna just pop
up out of the blue you're everywhere
okay well not anymore enjoy living in
your wife's Shadow dress warm
can't stand you
Why'd You Come here in the first place
man why don't you just let me live my
life in peace you bring this wake of
chaos with you giving me PTSD well maybe
the monks in Tibet will shield you from
all that
what am I supposed to do without you
I'm so used to you being everywhere
you're not supposed to be you're always
there to annoy me to unnerve me to to
get up under my skin and drive me
freaking crazy
the arguing the boiling of My Blood The
Sounds I make when I'm inside okay
Jesus Christ
can't stand it because I'm afraid that I
don't know who I'm gonna be when you're
not there
it frightens me I'm not me without you
I'm not
I need this even though I can't stand it
I can't stand to live without you
so what does that mean
you know what it means no yes you do you
know what it means
what does that mean [ __ ] you goodbye
Quentin
it means I love you okay I said it
said it are you happy no I have a flag
look get your ass back here
get it over here I'm talking to you get
your ass right back here
I'm not gonna beg you in front of all
these people man
okay I'm on one goddamn knee
okay I'm on both of my knees
look please don't leave me okay
Please Don't Leave Me
get off you idiot
I love you too
I've always loved you
wait not when you were with merch though
oh my God shut up and just kiss me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign